HBO is making a Game of Thrones prequel TV
show called House of the Dragon, based on
the Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
But they’re also developing another prequel
show based on the Tales of Dunk and Egg, a
series of novellas set ninety years before
A Game of Thrones.
Dunk is a young hedge knight.
He’s not particularly smart or skilled but
he’s tall and strong, and he’s determined
to be an honourable knight.
Egg is his loyal squire.
He has a bald head and a big mouth, and he’s
secretly a Targaryen prince, and future king
of Westeros.
We’ve already made videos about their first
two stories, where Dunk fights in a trial
at a tournament, then in a conflict between
minor lords.
But the third story is called The Mystery
Knight, and it’s a tale of conspiracy, sorcery,
prophecy, a dragon egg, painted dwarfs, homoerotic
‘jousting’ jokes and a lil baby Walder
Frey.
The Mystery Knight was adapted to a graphic
novel, with art by Mike S Miller.
At the start of the story, Dunk and Egg are
travelling north towards Winterfell, planning
to help the Starks fight against the ironborn.
This is a time of political tension in Westeros.
Cause the King, Aerys Targaryen, is seen as
“weak”, and he lets his uncle Bloodraven
rule the kingdom for him.
Many people hate Bloodraven – they call
him a sorcerer, a bastard.. and a kinslayer.
Cause sixteen years ago, Bloodraven’s half-brother
Daemon Blackfyre, started a rebellion to take
the Throne.
But at the Battle of the Redgrass Field, Bloodraven
killed his half-brother in a hail of arrows,
and Daemon’s surviving sons fled east across
the sea.
Now, sixteen years later, some people want
the Blackfyres to return.
Dunk and Egg see a preacher who says Bloodraven
is evil and the Blackfyres should rule Westeros.
Bloodraven doesn’t tolerate treason – so
he has the preacher killed.
Bloodraven has spies all over Westeros, it’s
said he has “A thousand eyes, and one”
–one eye on his face, cause he lost an eye
in the Blackfyre Rebellion, and the thousand
eyes of his spies.
Dunk and Egg take care while travelling, cause
there are “perilous times”.
Also, Egg gets a new hat, and he gives his
old hat to their mule, and even cuts out little
holes cut out for his ears, which is adorable.
The mule is named Maester, because it was
given to them by Egg’s brother, a young
Maester Aemon.
On the road, Dunk and Egg meet a group of
lords – there’s Gormon Peake, Alyn Cockshaw,
and this guy who calls himself “John the
Fiddler”.
Peake and Cockshaw are both rude to Dunk,
but the Fiddler is friendly.
He says he’s a humble travelling hedge knight,
like Dunk, all like ‘how do you do, “fellow
hedge knights”’.
But he wears rich clothes, and talks like
a lord, so he’s obviously not who he says
he is – the Fiddler and his friends are
up to something.
The Fiddler hits on Dunk – admiring how
“large” Dunk is, saying he would love
to “cross swords” with Dunk, and wants
to try his lance on him, but Dunk is oblivious
to the flirting.
The Fiddler is going to a castle called Whitewalls,
for a wedding and a tournament held by Lord
Butterwell.
So Dunk and Egg head there too – they hope
to win some money at the jousting, and eat
some good food at the feast.
Along the way, they meet some knights.
There’s Kyle the Cat who has “ginger whiskers”,
like a cat, a mysterious man called Maynard
Plumm, and a proud young knight called Glendon
Ball.
Glendon says he’s the son of Quentyn Ball,
a famous knight nicknamed “Fireball”.
Fireball was the master-at-arms who taught
young Targaryens how to fight – he trained
King Aerys, and Egg’s father Maekar, and
taught Bloodraven and Daemon Blackfyre.
When Daemon started his rebellion, Fireball
joined the Blackfyres, but died before the
Redgrass Field.
Glendon hopes to prove himself as a great
knight like Fireball by winning the tournament
at Whitewalls, and getting the grand prize
– a dragon egg.
The last dragon died sixty years ago, and
the remaining dragon eggs haven’t hatched
since.
So a famously unworthy king called Aegon the
Unworthy once gave a dragon egg to a Lord
Butterwell in return for his daughters.
Now, Lord Butterwell is offering this egg
as a tournament prize, and Dunk wonders why
he’d give away something so valuable.
At Whitewalls, Lord Butterwell marries a daughter
of Lord Frey.
We also see Lord Frey’s four-year-old son,
who ninety years later, grows up to be Lord
Walder Frey in the main series.
Dunk says this kid is “snot-nosed” and
“hideous”, and has such an “irritating
laugh” that he wants to throw the boy down
a well.
If he did, then maybe the Red Wedding wouldn’t
have happened, ninety years later.
The lords propose toasts to the bride and
groom, to the king, and to the king’s Hand,
Bloodraven.
But many at the feast hate Bloodraven and
refuse to toast him.
And when they toast to the king, Glendon holds
his wine cup over a basin of water.
This is a reference to a real historical practice.
In the 1700s, Britain was ruled by House Hanover,
but a group called the Jacobites wanted the
Stuarts to be king.
Charles Stuart lived in exile overseas in
France [and elsewhere in continental Europe].
So when the Jacobites toasted to the king,
they held their cups over water to show that
their king is Charles Stuart, the king ‘over
the water'.
In The Mystery Knight, Glendon does the same
thing, showing that he supports the Blackfyres
‘over the water’ in Essos.
Real history inspired a lot of this series.
So Dunk and Egg start to realise that many
people at this tournament support the Blackfyres,
not the Targaryens – Egg says “This is
a traitors’ tourney”.
Still, Dunk enjoys the feast, and drinks a
lot, and when he goes out for a piss, he overhears
a conversation between Gormon Peake, and Butterwell’s
son-in-law, “Black” Tom Heddle.
Tom complains that they don’t have Bittersteel’s
support.
Bittersteel is the half-brother of Daemon
Blackfyre, and was one of his main supporters
in the Blackfyre Rebellion.
When Daemon was killed, Bittersteel went east
with Daemon’s sons, and has plotted invasion
of Westeros ever since.
Peake says they don’t need Bittersteel’s
help, because their prince had a dream that
the dragon egg will hatch.
So Peake and Black Tom and Lord Butterwell
and Frey are plotting a second Blackfyre rebellion.
This whole tournament and wedding is an excuse
to bring together Blackfyre supporters, to
kick off a war for the throne.
But who is their prince with these dreams?
At the feast, some dwarfs perform, and Dunk
carries the bride to her bedding.
Dunk is really drunk by then, so he goes for
some air, and finds John the Fiddler.
The Fiddler is also pretty wasted, and he
says that his dreams come true – like, he
once dreamed that his brothers would die and
then they died.
He also had a dream that Dunk will join the
Kingsguard, the greatest knights in the realm.
And he dreamed that a dragon egg will hatch
at Whitewalls.
The Fiddler believes he will win the dragon
egg at this tournament, hatch a dragon, and
become the king of Westeros, with Dunk in
his Kingsguard.
So the Fiddler is the prince in Peake’s
conspiracy.
Cause his real name is Daemon Blackfyre the
Second, son of Daemon the First – he came
across the sea to start a new war for the
throne.
And there were hints of this earlier – the
Fiddler gives a toast to his “brave brothers”,
which refers to his dead Blackfyre brothers.
The Fiddler smells of “eastern spice”
– because he just came across from Essos
in the east.
The Fiddler dyes his hair black to hide the
blonde, but his eyes are the purple of Targaryens
and Blackfyres.
Peake shuts up the Fiddler before he gives
away their whole conspiracy, and Dunk falls
into bed.
In the morning, it’s hot, Dunk is super
hung over, he barely remembers that Blackfyre
stuff, and he just wants to get through the
jousting tournament without throwing up.
Dunk isn’t actually very good at jousting
with a lance – he’s better with a sword
in a fight.
But he just needs to win two jousts to make
some money.
His first opponent is some guy called Uthor
the Snail, so like how tough can he be, right?
Dunk and the Snail charge at each other, and
Dunk.. gets smashed in the head really hard,
and falls down.
Dunk wakes up hours later with the mother
of all headaches, but alive.
He says hi to the dwarfs from the feast last
night, and one of them smells like a toilet
which is weird…? but Dunk has bigger problems.
Cause at this tournament, when you’re defeated
in a joust, the knight who beat you gets your
horse and sword and armour, and you’ve got
to pay a ransom to get your stuff back.
But Dunk lost his first joust, and he doesn’t
have the money for a ransom, so.. it looks
like his life as a knight is over.
Maynard Plumm says Dunk should just keep his
stuff and run.
But Dunk refuses to cheat.
So he gives his stuff to Uthor the Snail.
Uthor’s tent looks plain from the outside,
but inside, it’s luxurious and comfortable
– Uthor lurks inside here like a snail in
his shell.
It turns out that Uthor is like a professional
jousting grifter.
Cause he’s really good at jousting, but
he hides his skill.
He deliberately never wins tournaments, only
getting second or third prize, so that people
always underestimate him.
And he bribes the people running this tournament
so he goes up against knights who look tough
but actually suck, so the Snail and his squire
can make money by taking bets against himself.
Uthor offers to give Dunk his arms back if
he joins in on Uthor’s con.
But Dunk refuses this dishonesty and corruption
– he’d rather give up his knighthood than
his honour.
Uthor tells Dunk the story of Glendon Ball,
the kid who says he’s the son of Fireball.
Apparently, Glendon’s mother was a camp
follower called Penny Jenny who was with so
many soldiers that there’s no way of knowing
if Fireball really is Glendon’s father.
Glendon was raised in a brothel, and he was
only knighted.. in return for a knight having
his sister.
So all the lords at this tournament look down
on Glendon as the baseborn son of a whore,
knighted dishonourably.
Glendon hoped to win some respect in the jousting
– cause Glendon is really talented knight.
But no matter how many times he proves his
skill, the lords still treat him like trash.
Dunk sympathises – he’s often been treated
the same way, as a bastard orphan from Flea
Bottom.
It’s so unfair that in this class system,
people are judged by who their parents were
instead of by their actions and their talent.
As a Japanese philosopher once said, “the
circumstances of one's birth are irrelevant;
it is what you do with the gift of life that
determines who you are”.
It's ironic that Glendon and Dunk treated
like they’re not real knights, when these
guys are practically the only honest honourable
knights here.
Uthor has his jousting grift, Maynard says
to break the rules, Kyle the Cat deliberately
loses his joust to suck up to a lord.
And it turns out that Peake is bribing people
to make sure Daemon wins the tournament.
But when he tries to bribe Glendon to lose
to Daemon, Glendon refuses.
So Glendon might not really be Quentyn Ball’s
son, and Dunk might not really have been knighted
in his first story.
But these guys are the truest knights here,
and they become friends.
As the jousting continues, rain falls down
from dark ominous clouds.
Butterwell’s dragon egg mysteriously goes
missing, so Peake falsely accuses Glendon
of stealing it.
And then a different egg goes missing – Dunk’s
squire Egg.. disappears.
Alyn Cockshaw says he knows where to find
Egg, so Dunk follows him into a trap.
It turns out, Alyn is in love with Daemon,
they’d had a relationship for years – and
it’s hinted that Daemon being gay was why
Bittersteel didn’t support his rebellion.
But Alyn is jealous that Daemon now wants
Dunk instead of him.
So Alyn actually paid Uthor to kill Dunk in
the joust, and that’s why he hit Dunk in
the head.
Since that didn’t work, Alyn tries to kill
Dunk himself.
He attacks Dunk with a dagger, so Dunk beats
him with a rock, and throws him down a well.
The excellent Radio Westeros podcast points
out that this fight between Dunk and Alyn
is similar to a fight in the main books between
Brienne and a guy called Shagwell, which also
involves a dagger and a rock and a well.
In Dunk’s fight, rock beats dagger, but
in Brienne’s fight dagger beats rock – it’s
like rock paper scissors.
And in the previous Dunk and Egg story, Dunk
fought a man in a stream – which is similar
to Brienne’s fight with Jaime, which, in
the books, happens in a stream.
And in the first Dunk and Egg story, Dunk
defeats Aerion in a similar way to how Brienne
defeats Loras Tyrell – by knocking him down,
raising his visor, and making him yield.
So in each of these three fights, Brienne’s
story echoes Dunk’s story.
Which makes sense, because author George Martin
has said that Dunk and Brienne are related
– he might be her great-grandfather.
Dunk and Brienne are both tall powerful warriors
who travel Westeros with their loyal squires
by their sides, struggling to be true knights
in a society that looks down on them.
So Dunk kills Alyn, then suddenly Maynard
Plumm appears, and helps Dunk with his wound.
Maynard seems to know all about Daemon and
Peake’s conspiracy, but only gives hints
at his own motives and identity.
He tells Dunk to find Egg in the sept.
Egg had wanted to help Dunk, and to prevent
this Blackfyre rebellion against his family
the Targaryens, so Egg went to Butterwell,
and revealed his true identity as Prince Aegon
Targaryen, and threatened him with attack
and execution – Egg acts with the confidence
and courage of a prince.
Black Tom Heddle tries to take Egg hostage,
so he and Dunk have a big fight, and Dunk
proves that he really is better with a sword
than with a lance.
It's hitting the fan, so Dunk tells Egg to
ride for safety.
But Dunk walks right up to Daemon, in front
of everyone, reveals his conspiracy, and demands
“Justice” “for Glendon Ball”.
Dunk knows it’s super dangerous for him
to publicly oppose Lord Peake.
He’s standing alone against a deadly political
conspiracy, to protect this bloke Glendon
who he barely knows.
Uthor asks if Dunk is gallant or just stupid.
But to Dunk, foolishness and heroism are sometimes
the same thing.
In his first story, Tanselle said “All men
are fools, and all men are knights”.
Fighting against impossible odds to help others
is foolish, but it’s also true heroism.
Luckily, Daemon wants the truth – he didn’t
know that Peake was rigging the tournament
for him.
So Daemon challenges Glendon to a trial by
combat to decide his innocence.
Glendon was “savagely” tortured in the
dungeon.
He’s burned and beaten, missing teeth and
fingernails, and now, to win his life, he’s
got to defeat Daemon Blackfyre.
Glendon laughs at the irony, cause Glendon
wanted to fight for the Blackfyres, just as
his father Fireball had.
Glendon would have joined Daemon if he’d
asked.
But since Glendon had refused to cheat and
lose for this conspiracy, now he’s gotta
fight against Daemon.
Daemon washes out his hair dye, and reveals
his Blackfyre colours, looking just like his
father Daemon the First.
Glendon has a fireball on his shield, just
like his supposed father, Quentyn.
The story asks “is the boy his father’s
son?”
Is Glendon a great knight like Fireball?
Is Daemon a true warrior and leader like his
father, Daemon the First?
The two knights crash together, and Daemon
Blackfyre splats into the mud.
The crowd laughs, and calls him “The Brown
Dragon”.
So Daemon the Second is not a warrior and
leader like his father Daemon the First.
But Glendon is a great knight like Fireball,
even though Fireball probably isn’t Glendon’s
father.
It’s like how Jon Snow isn’t Ned Stark’s
son, but he does embody Ned’s values and
legacy.
So maybe greatness and family isn’t in your
blood.
Maybe it’s something you can choose.
Suddenly, a Targaryen army arrives to crush
this rebellion, led by the Hand of the King,
Bloodraven himself.
Daemon tries to rally the castle to fight
Bloodraven, to rise up in a second Blackfyre
rebellion.
But Daemon’s cause seems hopeless and false.
He didn’t win his tournament, it was rigged,
and got beat into the mud by a bastard boy
anyway.
He doesn’t have a dragon egg, or the dragon
he said would hatch.
He doesn’t have Bittersteel, or an army.
And he doesn’t have the legendary sword
Blackfyre, the sword that gave Daemon the
First his name.
Politics in Westeros is about symbols of power
and legitimacy, and Daemon has nothing.
So in the end, Daemon rides out alone against
Bloodraven.
Bloodraven arrests Daemon, and burns his Blackfyre
flag.
“The First Blackfyre Rebellion had perished
on the Redgrass Field in blood and glory.
The Second Blackfyre Rebellion ended with
a whimper”.
Bloodraven arrests everyone, and decides who
to pardon and who to kill.
He spares Butterwell, but takes his money,
and destroys his castle.
And he kills Lord Peake.
Daemon he keeps as a prisoner, cause so long
as he’s alive, his younger brothers in Essos
can’t claim to be the new Blackfyre king.
Lord Frey, who married his daughter to Lord
Butterwell, and seemed involved in the conspiracy,
doesn’t get punished, and seems friendly
with Bloodraven – it looks like he might
have switched sides to inform on the conspiracy
to Bloodraven.
So even ninety years ago, you can’t trust
a bloody Frey.
Then Dunk faces Bloodraven’s judgement.
Bloodraven got his name from the raven-shaped
birthmark on his face.
He’s an albino, with red eyes, and his skin
and hair are white as bone.
Bloodraven looks similar to Elric of Melniboné,
a fantasy character by Michael Moorcock who
is also a warrior and sorcerer, with red eyes,
and skin and hair that’s bone white.
Bloodraven asks what the hell Dunk and Prince
Egg were doing here in the middle of this
rebellion.
Dunk says they just sorta accidentally wandered
into it, but Egg says they had it all under
control.
Egg demands gold so Dunk can buy back his
arms and armour, and demands that Glendon
should be released, and rewarded.
Egg finds new confidence in this story – confronting
Butterwell, revealing his identity, acting
like a prince.
And Bloodraven says that this fulfils Daemon’s
dream about a dragon hatching – it wasn’t
a literal dragon hatching from a literal egg.
The egg was Egg, and the dragon is his new
confidence as Prince Aegon Targaryen.
But what happened to the actual dragon egg?
Who stole it?
Bloodraven reveals that those dwarfs who performed
at the feast worked for him, and one of them
climbed up through a toilet, to steal the
dragon egg for Bloodraven.
That foul-smelling dwarf who Dunk saw was
the thief.
So Dunk and Egg ride off into the sunset,
but there’s another mystery the story doesn’t
answer.
- the mysterious Maynard Plumm.
What was he up to?
He’s this knowing, watching figure throughout
the story, but at the end, he disappears – right
before Bloodraven arrives.
Dunk notices there’s something strange about
Maynard’s face.
For one moment, he appears as “a hooded
shape” with “a single pale” eye.
It’s implied that Maynard Plumm is actually
Bloodraven in disguise.
Cause Bloodraven is said to be a sorcerer.
That he can “change his face”, and that
crows and wolves spy for him.
Which is probably true, cause ninety years
later, Bloodraven becomes the three-eyed crow,
a magical greenseer who trains Bran to control
animals to spy.
And when Dunk and Egg meet Maynard, he’s
in a grove of weirwood stumps, and weirwoods
are connected to the magic of the old gods.
Butterwell’s castle has rafters made of
weirwood, which might also hint that Bloodraven
is watching.
But Bloodraven’s disguise as Maynard is
probably a kind of magic called a glamour.
In the main books, Melisandre magically disguises
Mance Rayder to look like Rattleshirt.
And this magic is connected to a ruby Mance
wears.
Similarly, Maynard wears this giant moonstone
brooch, which might be the key to his magical
disguise.
So all this time, Bloodraven, the Hand of
the King, was watching the treason and conspiracy
at Whitewalls, learning who the traitors are,
securing the dragon egg, deciding who to execute
later.
But at the same time, he’s having a whole
lotta fun.
He drinks and gossips and jokes.
He jokes that maybe he’s the son of Aegon
Targaryen the Fourth, when Bloodraven really
is a bastard son of Aegon the Fourth.
He says the north is “too cold” for him,
which is funny cause Bloodraven later goes
far north beyond the Wall.
At the feast, Maynard makes crude jokes about
teats, and he calls Lord Butterwell “Lord
Butterbutt”.
Bloodraven is a ruthless politician spying
on his enemies, but he’s also a magical
trickster dressing up and getting on the beers
with the boys.
It’s a lot like the Norse god Odin, who
also had one eye, and spied with ravens, and
liked to magically disguise himself as a mortal
and make jokes about titties.
So you can see inspiration from mythology,
fantasy, and real-life history in this story.
The story also reveals the dangers of dreams
and prophecies.
Daemon is convinced that his rebellion will
succeed because of his dragon dreams – and
his dreams do come true, but not in the way
he expected – cause the hatching dragon
egg is actually a metaphor for Prince Egg.
And yeah, Dunk does eventually join the Kingsguard,
but he guards King Egg, not King Daemon.
Daemon’s dreams don’t lie, he just misinterprets
them, believes what he wants to believe.
And this happens all throughout the series.
Melisandre convinces herself that Stannis
is the prophesied hero Azor Ahai.
And she mistakes a vision of Alys Karstark
for a vision of Arya – the vision was true,
but her reading was false.
Cersei thinks the prophecy of Maggy the Frog
means that Margaery and Tyrion will destroy
her – but it might actually be Daenerys
and Jaime and Cersei’s own self-destructiveness
that will destroy her.
And the Targaryens have been tormented by
dreams and prophecies for centuries – King
Aerys, King Jaehaerys, Maester Aemon, and
Rhaegar, were all obsessed with prophecy,
hoping to bring back the dragons or the prince
that was promised to save the world.
But Aemon says that all of his brothers were
killed by their dragon dreams.
Daeron drank himself to oblivion, Aerion drank
wildfire thinking it’ll transform him into
a dragon, and Egg had dragon dreams that led
to death at Summerhall – but that’s a
story for another video.
And above it all, for a hundred years, Bloodraven
has watched over House Targaryen, ruthlessly
protecting the royal bloodline from the Blackfyres.
What dreams and prophecies has he seen?
And what do they mean for the destiny of Daenerys
and Jon Snow, the last of the Targaryen bloodline,
who themselves have prophetic dreams of fighting
the dead with fire?
If Dunk and Egg is anything to go by, their
dreams don’t mean what we think.
The Mystery Knight is the third and final
of the published Dunk and Egg stories, but
author George Martin plans to write more,
maybe ten or twelve to tell the whole life
stories of Dunk and Egg.
He says possible future titles include “The
She-Wolves of Winterfell” about the Starks
in the north, which some fans think might
involve a romance between Dunk and a young
Old Nan.
“The Village Hero” is set in the Riverlands,
and might involve the infamous Brute of Bracken.
“The Champion” might be about Dunk’s
fight against the Laughing Storm, Lyonel Baratheon.
“The Kingsguard” and “The Lord Commander”
might be about Dunk in King Egg’s Kingsguard.
There are still three more Blackfyre rebellions
to cover, and the story of how Egg became
king.
Dunk might reunite with his crush Tanselle,
or with Rohanne, or get revenge on Bennis.
There’re lots of possibilities for future
Dunk and Egg stories, and maybe their final
tale will end with Summerhall.
For now there are three published stories,
and you can get all of them on audiobook for
free right now at audible.com/asx.
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms includes all
three Dunk and Egg stories, read on audiobook
by Harry Lloyd, the actor who played Viserys
on Game of Thrones.
Or you could get Dune, or His Dark Materials,
or The Expanse.
Just sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial later.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
The trial is free, so it’s a pretty good
deal – sign up at audible.com/asx, or text
asx to 500-500.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to the Patrons,
including Matthew Mchale, Monty, Owen Jones,
Luca Maragò Savorelli, Mike Batko, and Willy
Hardy.
Cheers.